a historic agreement the united arab
emirates and
israel two countries that never had any
diplomatic relations
until thursday's deal and the idea was
very clear that israel will commit
in a three-way phone call with the
united states
to stopping annexation
suspending it and at the same time
we will be able to also announce
that we will begin what what i would
call
a normal relationship with israel in
various various areas
israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu greeted the deal as a huge
step towards peace in the region
well today we are sharing a new era of
peace between israel and the arab world
this is the greatest advancements toward
peace between israel and the arab world
in the last 26 years
specified that his annexation plans have
not been
outright cancelled rather only put on a
temporary hold
the agreement brokered by u.s president
donald trump
over months of discussions is seen as an
unprecedented reshaping of the political
order in the middle east
it comes as a diplomatic win for trump
just as the election campaign in the u.s
starts to heat up by uniting two of
america's closest and most capable
partners in the region
something which said could not be done
this deal is a significant step towards
building a more peaceful
secure and prosperous middle east
but not everyone is satisfied with the
agreement
the palestinian leadership dubbed the
deal a betrayal
and demanded its retraction
the palestinian leadership affirms that
neither the uae nor any other party has
the right to speak on behalf of the
palestinian people
and does not allow anyone to interfere
in palestinian affairs
or report on their behalf in their
legitimate rights to their homeland
as around the world the agreement is
being hailed as a historic achievement
the palestinians see themselves pushed
to the sidelines
for more let's bring in robert
chatterjee he's the deputy editor of the
german political magazine zenith which
focuses
on the middle east thanks for joining us
this morning robert
um a reshaping of the mideast
political infrastructure can you tell us
can you sketch out for us who the
winners and who the losers are
in this development
well at short term a lot of parties can
feel like
winners although i would not call this a
historic
shattering moment this has been in the
making for quite some years
especially the emirates and israel have
been developing
relations for many years and that was
one of the worst kept secrets
of the region also benjamin netanyahu he
visited oman
shortly before the sultan's death a
conference
preparing the so-called middle east
peace plan was held in bahrain
last year so a lot of
steps led to this now the timing is
crucial here um so why did this happen
now this is more the important question
and who needs this
uh strategic public victory right now
so from the u yeah um
the israeli government um i think they
uh can
hand a short-term victory to um the u.s
allies
at the same time it was never really
clear how much israel was prepared to
follow through
with these annexation plans and they
have to keep in mind
and brace for potentially different u.s
administration coming in next year
so calling it off temporarily looks like
a good wolf
gesture the annexation the potential
temporarily exactly and at the same time
israel did
yeah let me ask you is the region more
stable now as a result of this
nothing really changed that much and
israel basically did not commit to
anything
permanently and that would be a hot
topic of contention because it's not
entirely clear
if an agreement has been reached or if
that agreement is to be reached
in the negotiations to come and what
part annexation plans will play in this
okay negotiations to come could we see a
resurrection of the two-state solution
for palestine
well that depends on which parties um
are
are in there and willing to actually
move this forward i don't
see really um willingness on any part
um to to do that basically it's uh
it's it's negotiations between israel
and
a bunch of gulf arab states they have
a lot of common interest even outside
any
u.s help so they would have
proceeded with these kind of negotiate
negotiations
anyway irrespective of the palestinian
question
briefly could you see other arab states
joining in we have just a couple of
seconds
so yes or no
yeah the odd man out now is saudi arabia
so
the uee has clearly taken the forefront
as the most important
publicly visible ally of the of the
united states
and just one last thing we have to pay
attention to
the main architect of this policy this
is
muhammad bin zayed the crown prince of
abu dhabi probably the most influential
arab politicians in our time
he's stepping out of the shadows step by
step so
keep a close look how he's behaving
robert chatterjee from zenith magazine
here in germany
you